فرض صوتي وسط مخاوف غربية من
قدرته على حمل رؤوس نووية. ايلون
نعم فلدينا روبوتات صينية مسلحة
جاهزة للمعارك ودبابات مصغرة
العاب الجايمنج فيا لا دهائكم يا
اصحاب العيون الضيقة. الاحداث
والتطورات. الخارجية الجزائرية
زيارة رئيس البلاد الى روسيا يتم
وسط مخاوف متصاعدة من ان تبدأ
الصين عملا عسكريا في منطقة
على خلفية قضايا عدة. ابرزها
الازمة الاوكرانية والقلق الغربي
نتحدث. هنا وزارة الخارجية
الصينية تصرح انها اتخذت خطوات
دما. هم يأكلون كل شيء فلتحذري
يا كندا. نعم عن العيون الضيقة
ومولدوفا ومعظم الدول الاوروبية
اذا هذا هو الحال في القارة
الفرنسية. وهو الحال ذاته في
المانيا التي اجتاحتها المظاهرات
الرئيس ماكرون مساعدات بقيمة
مليار دولار للدول الافريقية.
التمريض قبل نهاية العام الحالي
بينما يواصل عمال مترو العاصمة
الفرنسية يرثى لها في ظل ارتفاع
الاسعار بسبب ازمة التضخم في
الاقتصاد البريطاني يلفظ انفاسه
الاخيرة ليهرب البريطانيون الى
عليها في دعم انضمامهما الى
الناتو مع تصويت برلماني قبل
وبعد دخول جيشها خرسون طالبت
كييف القوات الروسية بالاستسلام
الاوكرانية الطرقات والجسور
لعرقلة انسحاب القوات الروسية
مليون دولار للتحول للطاقة
النظيفة. البرلمان اللبناني يفشل
في الحرب الروسية الاوكرانية.
لكن ماذا عن تقدم الصين نحو
وماذا بعد يا ابناء زايد? بايدن
يعتذر عن انسحاب الولايات
التهديدات التركية ويبدأ اعمال
الحفر والتنقيب عن الغاز الطبيعي
ان اي صراع في تايوان قد يؤدي
الى صدمة اقتصادية عالمية ضخمة
متأهبة تحمل مقذوفات واسلحة يتم
انزالها بالدرونز على جبهات
القتال وكل ذلك بضغطة زر فهل
ستكون الحرب الصينية اشبه بمعارك
كالصين وبين هذا وذاك الولايات
المتحدة تحذر الدول الاوروبية من
فيها المحتجون بالابتعاد عن دعم
اوكرانيا وكذلك الوضع في تشيك
من تعاظم نفوذ الصين. فهل
للكنديين قوة لمجابهة دولة عظمى
ستشتري مائة الف طلقة من ذخيرة
المدفعية عيار مائة وخمسة وخمسين
دعمها للقوات الاوكرانية. اذ
تقوم المملكة المتحدة بتدريب
اقرب ما نقول عنها انها ماكرة.
الولايات المتحدة الامريكية
الرئيس الامريكي المقبل مرة
اخرى. الشتاء قد يوقف التقدمات
اشتريتها يا هذا؟ مصر تسجل
ارتفاعا جديدا لبيانات التضخم
السنوي سعار الاكل والشرب هي
الاكثر تأثرا فيا لتعاسة شعبك يا
زي بعضها يا جماعة. فطوابير
الطلاب امام مطاعم الجامعات
البريطانية اضرابهم والهدف تحسين
اجورهم. ومن بريطانيا الى فرنسا
ام الدنيا. بايدن ساعمل على منع
عودة ترامب للسلطة ولن يصبح هو
وحطم اقتصاداتها ليذوق اليوم
الاوروبيون من نفس الكأس.
المكلف. فيما تستعد انجلترا
لمواجهة اكبر اضراب بقطاع
للمرة الخامسة على التوالي
بانتخاب رئيس جديد للبلاد. فهل
المتحدة من اتفاق باريس للمناخ
مؤكدا ان لدى ادارته اجندة
لمواجهة تغير المناخ داخل البلاد
وخارجها. ويقدم لمصر خمسمائة
ماسك لموظفي تويتر. لا نستبعد
افلاس المنصة. اذا فلماذا
الكيان الاسرائيلي الاكبر يصل
الى الامارات العرب الى التطبيع.
التحضير لها. ونأمل ان تحصل قبل
نهاية العام. اليونان يتجاهل
هناك مرة سادسة يا هؤلاء؟ الحرس
الثوري الايراني يعلن صنع صاروخ
نعود الى المفاوضات النووية حيث
اعلن نائب وزير الخارجية الروسي
نهاية العام. فكيف تبدل الحال
اليوم بينما تنتظر تركيات شروطها
ستورت للاسلحة النووية تم
تأكيدها وستعقد في مصر. الربيع
قبالة سواحل جنوب وغرب جزيرة
كريت. فكيف سترد انقرة? حاخام
العجوز لكن السوء يتفاوت من دولة
الى اخرى. جيش الصين. لا ينزف
بانها قوة عالمية مدمرة. ياتي
ذلك في ذروة التوتر بين البلدين
صارمة ضد كندا في اعقاب وصف
وزيرة الخارجية الكندية لبكين
المحيط الهندي لترد الصين بهذا
الرد وداعا لقوات المشاة وسادة
المتشردين للحصول على الاكل
المجاني في الوقت الذي يقدم فيه
البلاد والطلبات في بات يلجأ
بعضهم الى جمعيات اطعام
صحيفة بولليتكو ان الادارة
الامريكية ضغطت على رئيس
الى استراتيجية السياسة العكسية.
جميع اعضاء الناتو وافقوا على
لترهق الدب الروسي؟ هنا وصلت
رسالة الامريكان وضغطهم الى
يقصد بايدن ان واشنطن ستقاتل في
اوكرانيا حتى اخر جندي اوكراني
واشنطن ستقدم لاوكرانيا القدرات
المعقولة للدفاع عن نفسها. فهل
الاوروبي يقترب. من حفر حفرة
لغيره لربما توسعت الحفرة يوما
واتسعت لكليهما. اوروبا صدرت
للعرب ربيعا دمر الدول العربية
بسبب ازمة الطاقة لترافقها
بالاحتجاجات الغاضبة التي طالب
ليستشيط الفرنسيون غضبا مع اضراب
واسع النطاق لقطاعات النقل
الدول العربية كمصر والجزائر
والمغرب والهدف الهروب من الشتاء
اوكرانيا. زينينسكي يقبل التفاوض
مع موسكو ولكن بشروط. حيث قالت
غربيون يصفون الانسحاب بالفرصة
الجيدة للتفاوض. وكل يغني على
الاستعطاف فهي المجر تقول ان
فنلندا والسويد يمكنهما الاعتماد
سيبطئ العمليات في ساحة المعركة.
مشيرا الى ان الانسحاب سيسمح
الروسي من خرسون والزلنسكي يقول
العدو لا يمنحنا الهدايا. وقادة
فهل يعود الروس للرد بقوة هذه
المرة ومن غبار المعارك بالقذائف
سيرجي رياكوف ان اجتماعات اللجنة
الاستشارية الروسية بشأن معاهدة
ساعديها وانطلقت لملاحقة قوات
موسكو المنسحبة حيث دمرت القوات
الاقل من القتال بحسب وبذلك
الدعم الغربي شمرت كييف عن
للموافقة لكن ماذا بعد موافقة
القرايا اعضاء الناتو؟ دعونا
عالمية ثالثة من خلال مقاتلات
امريكية لاوكرانيا. واضاف ان
حساب وهكذا هي الجيوش العظمى
تفرض قوتها في الكر والفر في
انضمام فنلندا والسويد للحلف
باستثناء المجر وتركيا وبقليل من
الجنود الاوكرانيين في مراكز
عسكرية بريطانية، وكذلك ارسال
دفعة جديدة من الاسلحة والمعدات
العسكرية. هنا دعم اخر وبطريقة
ما يكفي لتزويد وحدات المدفعية
الاوكرانية لعدة اسابيع على
ملليمتر من كوريا الجنوبية والتي
سيتم تسليمها الى اوكرانيا وهو
يتحدث يا ترى تخوف الاوكران من
الانسحاب الروسي يؤكده الرئيس
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين. وهذا ما
حدث. لتؤكد بريطانيا استمرار
تزعج بها دول اوروبا لتنال رضا
بوتين وبايدن يعتذر ويقدم لمصر
ليلاه لتعلنها وزارة الدفاع
الروسية سحبنا اكثر من ثلاثين
لكندا وتستعرض جيشا من الرجال
الاليين. الجزائر تقدم على خطوة
اوكرانيا كي يشطب من قائمة شروط
بدء الحوار شرط عدم التفاوض مع
الامريكي جو بايدن بقوله ان
بلاده لن تجازف بالدخول في حرب
لنهر دينيبرو. واضافت الوزارة
الروسية انها ستستهدف قوات كييف
مليار دولار. معارك روسيا لا
تتوقف. كل خطوة يحسب لها الف
وخدعة امريكية كورية تزعي الغرب
وفرنسا تصرخ والجيش الاوكراني لا
الف جندي وخمسة الاف وحدة من
الاسلحة والمعدات للضفة اليسرى
في خرسون بينما صرح وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني ان سحب روسيا قواتها
من مدينة خرسون الجنوبية يستغرق
اسبوعا على الاقل. وان الشتاء
لقوات الجانبين بالتفرغ للقتال
في اماكن اخرى. فعن اي اماكن
يتنازل عن اهم شروطه ليفتح بعدها
باب الحوار مع روسيا من جديد
يكتفي بانسحاب الروس من بعض
المناطق ليستفز موسكو بهذا
الاجراء فكيف سيرد الكرملين?
والصين تطلق تهديدا شديد اللهجة
بانفسنا لنشعل حربا علنية ثالثة
من اجل اوكرانيا فيما زلينسكي
ولكن مهلا ليس بالمتفجرات بل
بالمظاهرات والسبب بوتين وعشرات
تايوان? هل من جديد
الالاف من الجنود يتراجعون في
اوكرانيا وامريكا تقول لن نجازف
التقدم والانسحاب. لتعلن كييب عن
توجس اوكراني بشأن الانسحاب